you ever hear this idea that we have 5
to 10 to 20 pounds of toxic poop
stuck in our colons so today we're going
to talk about if that's actually a myth
or if there's some truth in it now i
have done
every cleanse that has ever been
invented i've done colonics i've done
colemas which is a combination of an
enema and a colonic which was invented
by bernard jensen who wrote the book on
colon cleansing i went to his home he
lived in a trailer in san diego
and i bought his kits and i've done many
of his colonics over the years and
looking back at that the problem was i
never fixed my diet so you'd go on a
seven-day kind of a colema cleanse where
you're doing this colema twice a day
morning at night and then you're not
eating any food you're taking
psyllium seed apple juice which is
filled with sugar and a bunch of
vitamins
and literally i was
starving because my blood sugars were up
and down because of the apple juice i
never
got into ketosis
and i was just
dreaming about eating a pizza because
they never told you to consume
electrolytes or sea salt so i was so
craving something salty and little did i
know i was very deficient in sodium and
that was actually quite dangerous to
drink all this fluid and then to
eliminate all this fluid so you really
need to know what you're doing if you're
going to do a colon cleanse
now how much toxic material is actually
in someone
could it be 5 10 20 pounds maybe with
some people but i don't think it's the
average i think the average person who
eliminates between
14 to 16 ounces of poop a day usually
does not have an impacted colon or
constipation now that's a generality you
know a lot of people do have
constipation and they could be holding a
lot more
waste however i do not think it's like
10 or even 20 pounds now in practice
there was one lady who came to see me
that was severely constipated she was
going to the bathroom once a month i'm
not kidding
and so yes she probably had more than 20
pounds of impacted poop in her gut but
of course when i did the evaluation i
found that her diet wasn't that great
and
after i got done explaining what to eat
uh she left and i never saw her again
but when she checked out at my front
desk
i went to lunch and i went outside and i
saw her car there and i walked by her
car and i happened to notice in the back
seat
it was
filled with
empty wrappers of
burger king mcdonald's
kfc
i mean she didn't even shoot him in the
garbage she stuck him in the back seat
so i think that had something to do
possibly
with um her constipation problem as well
as your toxicity
but i think the average person has this
idea
that
stool or waste is always toxic maybe
because it has an unpleasant smell
but think about what's happening you're
having
billions of microbes breaking down your
food and if the diet is poor you're
going to have
more of one microbe than another and
those microbes give off certain gases
that then have bad odor but if someone's
fairly healthy and they're eating
correctly they should not produce those
very unpleasant gases
that
other people might produce even when
someone has really bad breath whether
it's a softer smell or like a sewage
breath
that smell is not coming from toxins
it's coming from the gases produced by
certain microbes
that the person has an overgrowth and
it's the overgrowth of certain microbes
or yeast or or fungus that are producing
that bad odor and you know some people
have this idea that they just need to
flush out and cleanse
all this waste so then they can be
healthy and clean
but what happens when you're flushing
out all these microbes doing a colonic
or some herbal
laxative you're also fleshing out all
this friendly bacteria that you need to
help you digest the food it's kind of
like taking antibiotic one of the big
side effects is
constipation we depend on these microbes
to help us especially with the
consistency of our stool as well as the
frequency as well you know just like if
you're going to build a garden you're
going to make a compost pile that
material in the compost cannot break
down unless you have
like manure like animal waste which has
all the microbes if the microbes are not
in that material it will just sit there
it will not break down it won't decay so
we really need these microbes and mostly
in the large intestine to help us break
down things so in the digestive system
we have a lot of things that help us
break food down we have the stomach
acids
we have the enzymes that are produced
by our stomach in our pancreas and by
our small intestine that act on the food
in the small intestine
we have help from the liver and the
gallbladder producing the bile that
helps us break down fat so all these
things contribute to helping breaking
down food and then having it end up as a
waste but you have to realize that that
waste product is alive it's alive with
over a hundred billion microbes
just in one gram and 100 million viruses
per gram and when you're sick the viral
loads can go up to a trillion per gram
but these viruses i'm talking about are
friendly viruses that keep the bacteria
in check they don't affect our body they
kill bacteria to prevent the overgrowth
of bacteria so you have this interesting
balancing mechanism the point is that we
need these microbes desperately in the
absorption of food and for our immune
system and for many other reasons like
making vitamins but most of the microbes
are in the large intestine and as things
work you have this very long
tube from your stomach all the way down
to the rectum that is acting on this
food when you eat and normally at any
given time you should have about like
one pound of of material going through
your system because think about what's
happening this food is constantly
breaking down and being absorbed okay
because a lot of food
has water in it for example like even
steak is over 50 water and the body is
reabsorbing all this material through
the small intestine so 90 of the
digestion occurs in the small intestine
so it's like sucking out nutrition
amino acids fatty acids vitamins
minerals carbohydrates it's sucking it
out through the layer of your small
intestine and even a large intestine too
and it's going right into your
lymphatic system in your circulatory
system so just because you consume one
pound of food it doesn't end up as one
pound of waste and then when the
undigested particles end up in the large
intestine
the microbes act on those
and turn those into
a certain type of fat small chain fatty
acids that give you energy that feed
your colon
that help your blood sugars
so you have this incredibly dynamic
activity that's happening with this wave
or pumping action it's called
peristalsis that's supposed to push the
material through this digestive system
and have each part do a different thing
certain parts of your small intestine
for example will start to absorb trace
minerals for example certain parts of
the digestive system also help reabsorb
bile salts
which by the way give the stool its
color brown if you don't have enough
vital salts your stool becomes
lighter or pale or gray colored or even
tan
also if there's not enough bile
things become more constipated
if there's too much bile things become
looser you get diarrhea so all of these
different factors can act on the
material that's going through your
system having diverse types of fibers
like different types of vegetables can
help increase
the different microbes if you're always
eating one vegetable only your microbes
are not going to be as diversified and
so if someone's constipated they really
need to look at
microbes like probiotics as well as
fiber but i'm not talking about
metamucil or psyllium husk talking about
actual
food fiber from vegetables and when i'm
talking about a probiotic you can do
probiotics in foods like sauerkraut for
example has a lot of good bacteria other
fermented vegetables other fermented
dairy like kefir or you can buy a good
probiotic now to be totally transparent
i do sell a high quality probiotic but
you can find a probiotic anywhere just
make sure it's high quality and it
survives the stomach so there's a few
important things
you need to understand about this topic
number one
the solution to either constipation or
diarrhea
always relates to your diet so if you
are constipated and you're trying to add
more vegetable fiber to your diet and
that doesn't work and let's say you take
a probiotic and it still doesn't work
i'm not opposed to taking
a herbal laxative because that's a lot
better than a medication but just
realize the underlying cause of that
constipation definitely relates to your
diet there's something not right in your
diet maybe you need more bile salts
because your liver is too fatty and it
can't produce the battle salts maybe you
need more stomach acids or for example
more sea salt which is sodium chloride
to help you build more hydrochloric acid
or even you need more enzymes because
the pancreas is too exhausted because of
the constant introduction of
carbohydrates so anyway i wanted to
clear up some of these
interesting ideas people had in
relationship to
toxic poop and to give you the
understanding that not everyone has you
know pounds and pounds of toxic material
in their colon that they need to flush
out with a pill you really need to
figure out the diet because that's
really the ultimate
correction
of digestive problems now if you haven't
seen my video on how to use foods to
detoxify your liver i put that up right
here check it out
you